The awesome second season of The Umbrella
Academy just exploded onto our screens with
the gang arriving in the 60s to meddle with
the timeline, stop a new apocalypse, and leave
us with yet another epic cliffhanger for Season
3.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video we're breaking down everything
you need to know about that big twist ending,
including clues you might have missed about
the new characters, upgraded Umbrella Academy
powers, and what it all means for Season 3!
It goes without saying spoilers ahead, so
take care.
Season 2 ends on an all-mighty cliffhanger
when the Umbrella Academy return from the
60s to 2019 only to discover things are not
as they expected.
Not only is there a portrait of Ben on the
wall at the academy where the portrait of
Five used to be, but their father Reginald
Hargreeves is still alive and he drops this
bombshell:
"This isn't your home.
This is the Sparrow Academy."
A mystery group of five assemble above and
Ben 2.0 strides into view:
"Dad, who the hell are these assholes?"
This is a huge WTF moment for the Umbrella
Academy who suddenly discover they have no
home and no obvious future.
First off, some interesting details to point
out are that Ben, who is of course alive in
this new timeline,
seems to be the Sparrow Academy leader, the
equivalent of the Umbrella crew's Luther aka
Number One.
Notice the scar on his face, which he presumably
acquired on a mission, and also the coat of
arms on his jacket which has a sparrow in
the top-left quarter rather than an umbrella.
Something else you might have missed is a
mystery cube that floats into view next to
the other Sparrows on the balcony.
The cube has some glowing green light inside
and although it could be some kind of device
or invention the Sparrows use, it might also
be the seventh member of the team, perhaps
even a character who died like original Ben
and whose consciousness is contained within
the cube, perhaps like Robotman from Doom
Patrol.
Or if the cube itself is sentient, it makes
me think of the talking A.I., Mainframe, which
appears in one of the Guardians of the Galaxy
2 post-credits scenes
"I miss you guys so much."
If the cube is just a piece of tech though,
I wonder if the fact there are only six Sparrows
on screen could imply one of them is dead
or that there's a supposedly non-powered sibling,
like Vanya aka Seven, who's not yet part of
their super-team.
In the comics, the Sparrow Academy is a group
of superheroes who turn up at the very end
of the third volume of books to take down
a group of villains rampaging through the
city.
They seem more capable than the Umbrella Academy
who were basically losing the battle until
the Sparrows arrived.
Their leader calls himself "Number One" but
they have different powers to the Umbrella
team.
And the comic book Sparrows also have a cube
that floats alongside them.
Gerard Way, the comics writer and producer
on the Netflix show, has said the next volume
in the comics will begin to answer questions
about the other super-babies which strongly
implies that the Sparrows are indeed other
babies born on that fateful day.
The TV show will doubtless have its own plans
that will differ in some ways from the comics,
but what's especially interesting is that
there were sparrow motifs hidden all through
the second season foreshadowing the introduction
of this new team.
And you can see those secret sparrows in my
upcoming "Things You Missed" video.
But how did the Sparrow Academy come about?
Was Reginald Hargreeves so unimpressed with
the Umbrella team he met in 1963 that he decided
to form an alternative super-group: the Sparrow
Academy?
"Thank you for coming.
I've seen about enough."
Or did the Umbrella crew alter the timeline
so badly in Season 2 that they accidentally
wrote themselves out of the future?
Let's review the season's big events for evidence
and how this points to the existence of an
Umbrella Academy multiverse.
One of the crucial moments in Season 2 that
connects directly to the events of the first
season is when Old Man Five time travels through
a portal from 1963 to 2019.
However, when the scene plays out again in
the second season, there's a subtle but vital
difference.
In Season 2, we see Old Man Five fall backwards
through the portal into 2019 rather than falling
through face forwards as he did in Season
1.
And the Five that jumps forward in time to
2019 in Season 2 also has a whole lot of different
information to what he had in the first season.
For example, Luther already told him that
the eyeball he found in the apocalypse is
just a red herring:
"Yeah, that's a waste of time."
"Then why were you holding it when I found
you dead in the apocalypse?"
"No idea.
But the guy it belonged to didn't end the
world.
Vanya did."
The eyeball Luther is referring to belonged
to Leonard and so now when Five arrives in
2019 it won't make sense for him to chase
down leads on where the eye came from,
as he'd surely immediately tell the others
about Vanya.
Which means he will end up creating an alternate
timeline.
We've already seen the show touch on alternate
realities in the first season, for example,
Episode 6 "The Day That Wasn't", where Allison
and Luther dance.
But at the end of that episode when Five time-jumped
to an earlier point in that day, the show
followed on and began an alternate timeline
in which Allison and Luther never had that
kiss.
"We have never even kissed."
And there are so many other examples in Season
2 of major effects that the super-siblings
must have had on the timeline,
that it's easy to see why the gang arrive
back in a rather different 2019.
As Vanya pointed out in the 60s:
"Has anyone done anything here to screw up
the timeline?"
Klaus, for example, starts a cult that attracts
at least a few hundred followers and tries
to convince Dave not to sign up to fight in
Vietnam.
In fact, there's a clue in the sixth episode
that the timeline was already changing when
Klaus discovers that Dave has enlisted in
the army days before it originally happened.
And by the final episode, the whole Umbrella
crew end up on the national news as persons
of interest in the JFK assassination, something
which could have myriad repercussions on the
timeline.
In addition to that, Five killed the Commission's
board of directors, allowing the Handler to
take over.
Which means the Commission's decisions on
how they want the timeline to proceed could
be very different now,
which could lead to the formation of The Sparrow
Academy.
And given Reginald Hargreeves is still alive
in the new timeline, it's fair to assume that
Pogo and Grace who were killed during Vanya's
destructive rampage in Season 1 will also
be back in Season 3.
A crucial new character that will surely be
returning is Lila, who in the finale turned
out to be one of the 43 super-powered babies
born on the same day in 1989.
Lila's power set is fascinating as she can
reproduce the abilities of any of the Umbrella
Academy members in certain circumstances.
For example, when Vanya flattened the Handler's
army of assassins with an energy blast, Lila
was able to replicate Vanya's defensive powers,
by creating a shield that protected both her
and the Handler.
Lila can also mirror Vanya's other powers,
such as when she sent a powerful blast against
the Umbrella crew.
On top of that, Lila was also able to redirect
Alison's rumour back at her, almost killing
her.
"I heard a rumor..."
"...you stopped breathing."
And she also took on Luther's brute strength
when he tried to hit her.
Although Lila's huge power reveal was a surprise
in the finale, there was actually a hint to
her ability to mirror other people's powers
during her mid-season fight with Five when
she was able to blink just like he does.
"How are you doing this?"
"Anything you can do, I can do better."
Lila's ability to mimic other hero's superpowers
reminds me of the Marvel villain Taskmaster
who appears in the new Black Widow movie.
"So unoriginal."
It seems that Lila's abilities may be something
that's triggered temporarily,
such as when another super-powered individual
uses their powers because she doesn't seem
to use superpowers any other time.
Lila has a troubled backstory, with Five having
killed her parents after the Handler placed
a kill order on them so she could adopt the
gifted girl for herself.
So, Diego suggested that she join the Umbrella
Academy who he said were her real family,
however, she ended up escaping with a Commission
briefcase to an unknown time and location.
Is it possible that Lila is one of the members
of the Sparrow Academy?
Either way, she's far too interesting a character
not to return at some point.
As for Lila's adoptive mother The Handler,
by the end of season 2 her double-dealings
with the Swedes and her scheming against the
Umbrella Academy finally catch up with her
as the sole surviving Swede guns her down.
Presumably she's dead for good this time;
however, that also appeared to be the case
in Season 1 when Hazel shot her in the head,
but she survived thanks to the metal plate
in her head.
I wouldn't quite put it past her returning
in the future as she was such a fantastic
character, with her schemes and outfits getting
more and more outrageous as her powers grew
within the Commission;
though I suspect if she does reappear, it'll
be in flashbacks or yet another alternate
timeline.
Although the Umbrella Academy's very existence
comes into question when they get back to
2019,
by the end of Season 2 the team are actually
much stronger and more mature, with a better
understanding of who they really are and better
control over their powers,
which will be important for Season 3.
Vanya and Ben perhaps go through the biggest
arc with their fates converging in an emotional
ninth episode.
When Vanya arrives in 1963, she loses her
memory after being hit by Sissy's car, so
she starts with a blank slate and seems more
comfortable in her own skin than in the first
season.
Not surprising given that now she's not being
mistreated, constantly made to feel she's
worthless, or incessantly compared to her
super-siblings.
And as she rediscovers who she really is,
this time – unlike in Season 1
she has much more control over her powers.
She's able to voluntarily levitate a whole
body of water in order to rescue Harlan and
she breezily demonstrates how she can manipulate
a sound wave in front of Hargreeves and her
siblings.
She can even turn into the White Violin at
will as a way of warning Five, and then quickly
turn it off as well.
She has control over her energy blasts now
and curiously she almost seemed to make the
FBI agent's face implode when he was interrogating
her.
However, when she's drugged by the Feds and
electro-shocked, Vanya's memories of what
she did in the first season, including attacking
her sister Allison and destroying the world,
come flooding back.
"You can't deny your true self even if you
are afraid".
And the emotional overload sends Vanya's powers
out of control again.
That's when Ben becomes the hero of the moment
because, as a ghost, he's the only one who
can withstand the physical force that's blasting
out from Vanya.
Ben uses his newfound ability of possessing
another body to enter Vanya's psyche and communicate
with her.
He helps his sister come to terms with her
powers, and explains that she isn't a monster
and that her siblings love her and are out
there fighting to help her.
The brotherly love that Ben shares with Vanya
in this moment is very touching and restores
her sense of self-worth, bringing her back
from the brink of destruction.
This experience also gives Ben the resolution
he's been looking for for 17 years to leave
his current plane of existence.
There's a really nice visual of Ben walking
towards the light as he goes to help Vanya,
which relates to the conversation he had with
his brother Klaus at his own funeral:
"There's a light and they told me to walk
into it."
"That thing.
Don't worry about it."
"You can go whenever you want."
As for the others, Klaus develops his ability
to manifest ghosts other than Ben in the real
world.
When Lila's blast sends him flying for a potentially
lethal fall, he summons a couple of ghosts
to catch him safely.
And in the 1963 apocalypse we got a glimpse
of the potential of his powers when he summoned
an army of the dead.
Five finally masters time travel by limiting
his attempts to travel back in time to just
a few seconds or minutes rather than whole
years or decades at once,
and with this skill he's able to reverse everyone's
brutal deaths by the Handler.
Allison was unable to speak for a year until
her throat wound healed and because she couldn't
use her power, she felt more like everything
she accomplished was earned.
Given the situation she lands in though, her
inability then reluctance to use her powers
can feel more frustrating than usual.
But as Emmy Raver-Lampman told Den of Geek,
Allison sees her power "as more of a curse
than a blessing" as it's "always backfired
in the long game".
Still, by the end of Season 2, Allison seems
to feel she's found the right balance of when
to call on her ability.
Diego spends much of Season 2 really playing
up to his hero complex, and although it's
not entirely clear whether he resolved that,
his power to manipulate objects in mid-air
gets an upgrade in the final showdown when
he's able to redirect an enormous hail of
bullets.
And then there was that pretty awesome moment
during the 1963 apocalypse when if you look
really closely,
Diego is bending this stream of bullets away
from him as he spirals through the air.
In terms of their personal lives though, in
many ways the gang lose more than they gain.
Vanya finds a soul mate in Sissy but the dangers
of life as a super-powered individual mean
Sissy's scared for Harlan's safety if she
goes with Vanya.
However, a door is left open for a reunion
down the road:
"If you ever find a safe way back to me, you
take it."
If Vanya wanted to leave the team or settle
down, she could grab a Commission briefcase
and travel back in time to be with Sissy,
similar to how Hazel enjoyed his golden years
with Agnes in another timeline.
Each of the others also loses someone important
to them.
Diego loses Lila to the timeline, although
there's a good chance they will meet again;
and Allison had to give up her marriage with
Ray.
Klaus wasn't able to convince Dave not to
go to Vietnam
and when Ben leaves the earthly plane, he's
no longer able to see the girl he likes from
Klaus's cult.
As for Luther, when Jack Ruby disowns him,
he loses the father figure he never had.
"I treated you like a son"
Ok, time to discuss Harlan, Sissy's son, who
was gifted Vanya's telekinetic powers when
she resuscitated him after he appeared to
drown.
Those little lights that transferred into
him seem to confirm the theory that the glowing
lights we saw Hargreeves release in the Season
1 finale
are connected to the special powers inherited
by Vanya and likely all 43 super-babies born
in 1989.
Harlan's manifestation of powers triggers
a major alarm at the Commission, with the
Handler recognising the importance of the
event which is why she went immediately to
take Harlan for herself, like she did with
Lila.
Interestingly though, the transference of
power from Vanya to Harlan connects them both
even across distances.
Harlan goes into a trance when Vanya is being
tortured by the FBI, and emerges from it at
the same time that she comes out of her shock.
Harlan can also repel a bullet fired at him,
just like Vanya did when the Swedes tried
to shoot her.
And similar to Vanya in Season 1, when Harlan's
emotions get out of control after the deflected
bullet accidentally kills his father, he begins
to go supernova.
Vanya eventually is able to calm him down
when she removes those golden lights from
his body, however, as we see later when he's
levitating one of his bird toys, he still
retains at least some of the powers she gave
him.
Which makes me wonder whether Harlan might
grow up to be the father of any of the members
of the Sparrow Academy or even help form the
group with Hargreeves?
Season 2 goes deeper into Reginald Hargreeves'
backstory, revealing that he was working for
a time with a shadowy organisation called
the Majestic 12.
He had a deal to trade them his rocket technology
in return for leaving alone his interests
on the dark side of the moon.
Hargreeves objected to their assassination
of President Kennedy and attempted to leave
the group.
And when they tried to blackmail him, we got
the awesome reveal that he's really an alien
hiding underneath human skin.
We only get a glimpse of the back of his head
but the moment is a great nod to the same
reveal in the comics that Hargreeves wears
a mask to blend in as a human,
which also explains why he never seems to
age.
Something I really enjoyed in Season 2 was
getting to learn a lot more about the Commission
and in particular the Infinite Switchboard
where operators constantly monitor the timeline
for anomalies.
The Commission's all-seeing eye reminds me
of how whenever we're online, our internet
service providers are keeping records of our
browsing history and what that means for our
privacy.
Which is why I want to thank the sponsor of
this video NordVPN who offer one of the world's
best virtual private networks.
A VPN is essential to prevent your internet
service provider tracking your online activities
and sharing your data with governments or
even selling it to advertisers.
Here at Flicks And The City, we've tested
several VPNs and we know that some really
slow down your connection.
However, Nord strives to maintain super-fast
download and upload speeds on its 5,000+ servers
through the use of new-generation VPN technologies
like Wireguard.
So, when we tested Nord we were still able
to get blisteringly fast download speeds.
And one of the best features of NordVPN is
that unlike many free VPNs, Nord has a no-log
policy meaning it doesn't record or retain
details of your online activity when you're
connected to its service.
NordVPN also helps you connect to many streaming
services and can help you bypass geo-restrictions
or censorship on content not available to
view in your country.
Just pick a server in another location and
browse the internet as if you were there.
Plus you can connect up to six devices at
the same time, including your laptop and phone,
so you can keep your mobile devices safe whenever
you're travelling and using public wifi.
For a limited time, NordVPN are offering all
our viewers up to 70% off new subscriptions
and a bonus month absolutely free.
Just visit NordVPN.com/Flicks or tap the link
in the video description to access the offer.
That's NordVPN.com/Flicks for a huge 70% discount
and an additional month for free.
So, which are your favourite moments or characters
in Season 2?
And do you have any theories on the Sparrow
Academy or Season 3?
More Umbrella Academy videos are on the way
including all the amazing details you missed
in Season 2
So be sure to subscribe and leave a thumbs-up
if you enjoyed this.
Tap left to watch the next Umbrella Academy
video or tap right for something else you're
sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!